Mō tātou, a, mō ka uri a muri ake nei
In August we were pleased to officially open
Feldwick drive.
We had a great turn out both from local residents,
and the vintage car enthusiasts.
The Riverview Terraces continue to make good
progress, with the riverbank now looking a
lot tidier and the seating areas starting
to take shape.
When we developed the Recovery Plan for these
areas, the community really clearly told us
which facilities they wanted to have.
The draft Reserves Master Plan is effectively
a blueprint which shows how all those ideas
fit together in this space.
Developing the Reserves Masterplan is the
last key planning and design exercise before
we get into construction.
It's look at where the activities and features
will go, where pathways go, where we'll have
some key planting, where the stormwater management
areas are.
One key project is the construction of multipurpose
sport fields with changing rooms, toilets,
and parking.
It’s also planned to build two dedicated
softball diamonds, these will help cater for
the huge growth in the sport and allow tournaments
to be hosted in our district.
11 years ago we were two teams, we're very
close to 20.
It gives them the ability to have some very
good facilities to play on rather than just
a bit of dirt.
The planned dog park will have areas for both
small and large dogs.
We’re keeping many of the existing trees,
so it will look well established right from
the opening.
This has consistently been one of the most
requested facilities for the Regeneration
Areas.
I think there needs to be somewhere fenced
off close by for dogs and owners to be able
to let their dogs of the leash.
I think rubbish bins is a big thing that a
dog park needs and somewhere for the dogs
to be able to have a drink.
Careful thought and planning has gone into
making sure the reserves can be enjoyed by everyone.
Throughout all the new reserves, we've tried
to maximise walking and cycling tracks.
The tracks will link up to existing reserves
and to some of the key activities and features
we're proposing.
You can find out more about the draft Master
Reserves plan on the council website.
The first projects to get underway will be
the stormwater management areas, and work
will start on those in the next month.
We’ll take a closer look at the progress
in those in our next update.